we've got to kick everything off with a
sweet little nostalgic
nugget about leonardo dicaprio
pop sugar reports that leo's former
interior designer
megan weaver just revealed that his old
malibu beach house was
titanic themed it was decked out in
titanic towels
a titanic poster she would wear the
titanic robe around and the designer was
like wait a minute
all these titanic touches she doesn't
think they were put there by leo but his
proud mama ermilan
how cute is that okay see i think it's
so cute and if i was in like one of the
most
the highest grossing films of all time i
would have it two i was in the hobbit in
seventh grade you guys probably heard
about it i was a revelation
and i which character did you play the
hobbit thank you very much
and if i could get like ross matthews as
the hobbit bathmat when i was in seventh
grade yeah uh i woulda
yeah yeah yeah would you do you have
anything in your house like
nothing anyway i will say
nothing why not no it's all in boxes in
storage i don't need me
oh girl i would have me everywhere i
will say though that i've actually been
to leonardo dicaprio's like real home
and he is so not self-indulgent there is
no
me me me his taste is impeccable his art
collections to die for and
um i think this was like the cutest
thing ever
but he doesn't live like that to my
knowledge
all right next up time with black
history month google this is so cool
they're rolling out a brand new feature
that makes it even
easier to support black businesses house
beautiful reports that the new feature
is
already up and running right now you
just go to the google shopping tab
you search to whatever product you want
and in the results you'll be able
to see which stores are black owned
businesses you're looking right there
and they already have this feature in
google maps too so all your search
searches of uh local shops and
restaurants tells you that feature as
well
like i'm of the generation where like if
they asked me for my password i just
start crying
but my daughter can like hack you know
so
i just i love this it's respectful it is
user friendly
it's all the things and i can't thank
google more i really can't this is
perfection
because it's what we want to be doing
you know uh and but sometimes it can be
confusing like how do you get from your
intention to your to execution this
makes it so simple
i love that raw so much google
intention to execution thank you and
thank you ross
you just kind of surmised everything i
think and feel
i love it um okay i have been very open
about my love of old-fashioned snail
mail
and i'm real hot to trot for this
suggestion from
vogue they say that this valentine's day
you should make your own
valentine's cards like d.i wyatt yeah
they just make such
a difference you know they do i i was
thinking like when's the last time i
wrote
like a love letter or something and i
it's like never i've never done it
so i'm gonna do it this year let's do it
rossie yeah so he and he's watching
act surprise babe when you get it okay
i'm making it for you
but i i started by making you a
valentine's day card
rozzy i did it's i'd like to this is
what i mean oh my god it's so awesome
okay i'm gonna hand it to you
okay and you can put it down put it down
there you go okay
um i know it looks like a toddler did it
but i actually did do that that was
exactly what i was picturing when i was
saying
like those handmade cards oh my gosh i
love it
so much i can't even handle it okay okay
make me something i'm going to because
look i pulled this from home
i just had some like watercolor tubes
that's like the highly pigmented and you
add a little water to it so you just do
some colors
and i got some white paper i got my
favorite pair of scissors
and my jar of paint brushes and then
this is this little caddy i had made for
olive
when she was little one for her and
frankie um
so i'm gonna diy you i love valentines
you know what the things that are
handmade and special like
they're the ones that i've saved for my
entire life i still have them